okay so say we say we sort of offline
and like you know we improve layout and
paint and all that stuff that's great
and all but there's a another piece of
the puzzle missing and that's that's raw
computation you know so you want to do
something like a physics engine or you
know real-time video analysis you know
pick out things are in an image you know
face recognition over like a whole
audience full of people can we get the
performance of near native code without
without throwing security out of the
window well here to say yes and
hopefully some other words it's Molly
McKinley and David see ya everyone so it
is really the last talk of the day so I
don't keep you too long we're going to
talk to you about something we think is
a really great portable Native Client
I'm David Sarah and the TL of the Native
Client team and I'm Molly McKinley I'm
the p.m. on the Native Client team and
you are getting to your drink soon I
promise but we really appreciate your
attention for this final talk of the day
so I want to start off about where line
is started off with the fact that we
have a new web today our expectations
for what you can do on the web are
changing this native app on a phone
versus a native app on a computer versus
an website that you're navigating to
these are all starting to merge we
aren't in the 90s anymore back in 1995
we had a website that was mostly text
there were some links you could click on
some stuff but mostly it was text as you
can see we ended up at having a new ways
to link two things we had yahoo
microsoft and even google it was pretty
basic our interactions we had fast
forward to today and we have much more
rich ways of interacting with websites
now we have interactive video editing
data visualization ways of showing what
our solar system looks like and mapping
applications the web today is way more
reg one example the Google+ photos
application this is something that you'd
expect much more on desktop in Photoshop
than in a web application you just
navigate to I'm going to start off with
a fast demo
just to keep you guys from getting bored
so here hopefully is my lion let's go
into the edit mode move us over here
maybe resize our window a little bit
potentially drag the that might work
perfect okay lion huzzah you can do some
cool stuff like tuning our image you can
go and play with some sliders yourself
or just go with what they're suggesting
you could pop or moody kind of cool I'm
all as a pop person let's go saturation
level up can apply that for a little
while they also have a lot of really
cool filters you can apply just right
there some of my favorites are these
retro lux I not retro I don't know what
that really means but they look cool so
Voyager is a fun one you can also just
shuffle through it randomly until you
find one you like like wow that looks
funky okay let's apply that and then BAM
you have a completely different image
like I don't know photoshop i would not
know how to do that if you put me you
know on a native application and i had
to edit this pixel by pixel but you know
compare the images we have now i've
created a completely different and
different style image than I had before
it's a really rich experience and I
think you'll agree 20 years ago you
would not see this on a website today
we're expecting a lot more continuing on
these native features they're coming to
our web applications back in the day
AutoCAD it really could only exist on a
pc now there's a chrome app for that
we're not only asking for the native
capabilities in our web we're having to
ask developers to develop for many
platforms they have a C++ application an
objective-c application a JavaScript
application they're maintaining many
developments tax would it be great
if we could only maintain one stack that
could then be applied to these many
different platforms that's an ideal i
would like to fight for okay from almost
the beginning people recognized i think
the potential of the web platform but
but the as molly just described us a
second ago the web didn't really have
the capability at the beginning to do
some of these rich interactions that we
wanted so way back in the mid-90s
browser vendors added extension
platforms or extension api's what what
in fact were things like activex and
NPAPI these are ways to get at the
underlying operating system features for
things like you know embedding a media
controller so you can listen to your
your CDs in those days or put up a local
database server and these were ways as I
say they give you access to some of the
features that they felt were cool on the
native platform by drilling through with
these plugins to the underlying native
capabilities now because these were to
coding to the underlying native
operating system they tended to be
either platform specific in the case of
activex or things like NPAPI where you
had to kind of know which platform you
were going to be on so he was going to
be compiled for windows or for Linux or
for Mac depending upon which browser the
user happened to be running at the time
maybe a different set of browser API etc
so this is kind of a complicated
cumbersome sort of way of programming
these things and so you see at about the
same time these plugins come up that
provide capabilities for getting at
those underlying operating system
features but through better programming
approaches so you have Java you have
flash and its predecessors coming and
these are ways again that gave you
access to some of the underlying
features such as canvases to draw on or
underlying database engines etc and much
later then you have silver light which
is giving you the capability to do this
and of course across a broad spectrum of
languages on the.net framework so this
is sort of what happened between the 90s
and the mid-2000s we're plugins now
plugins
add a number of issues as I'm sure
you're all aware plugins have this it
user interaction where GI go to a page
and it says I need flash but I don't
have flash installed so I get this
pop-up saying I need to install flash or
I need silverlight 4 this content right
as a developer need to know am I going
to get to the people I want to get to if
they don't have the plugins installed so
it's kind of unfortunate interaction
that way and also the plugins tended to
be well you have what was running inside
the plug-in and you have what was
running outside the plug and there was
always a sort of jarring interaction
between them which made for sort of
clunky you I if you didn't really work
very hard at the isolating that or not
isolating that little box that had your
Java applet running at it from the rest
of the page and sort of most concerning
of all all of the plug-in API is
provided you with direct native access
to the operating system and that made
the possibility that bugs became
security issues and not just became
security issue became security issues
that were prevalent just about
everywhere and just about all the
plugins we see security issues that have
become this is 2009-2010 from Symantec
become serious issues for security in
the web so fast forward now to 2008 2008
javascript takes a new turn Colonel
ignites the JavaScript performance
spiral that we've all witnessed over the
last five years and you know the web's
not been static the browser has been
growing this open web platform that has
all these features we've been hearing
about today and we'll hear about
tomorrow and so it's a much richer
platform so with JavaScript performance
coming up and the platform getting
richer a new approach to bringing native
code to the web comes to the fore and
that's exemplified by M scripting and
scripting is you compile from native to
JavaScript and run it in the web
platform and in scripting we think you
know you get the access to the features
that you're after and some of the
performance most of the performance
perhaps but there's there are some some
issues still with in scripting the first
one is if you're really developing a
native application and it
memory management issues for instance
debugging a null pointer check in
javascript is not as easy as it sounds
also if you're trying to get to all the
native capabilities for instance threads
it's not there yet and and furthermore I
said most of the performance perhaps we
get to 2x within two acts of native
performance you would still like to get
to the remainder of that performance so
that brings us to why are we trying to
bring native code to the web why are we
talking about bringing native code to
the web we still as i said we still
think there's there's better performance
yet to be had from features like
threading as well as from that last
fifty percent or more and also
increasing the developer options so in
this team we started the Native Client
project and Native Client project was
about bringing native capabilities
threads cindy instructions etc from the
beginning bringing performance trying to
get as close to native performance as we
could get while still securely executing
your application in the web browser and
a familiar developer model so you can
use gdb and you can if you're a native
developer you can debug in the way that
you've become accustomed to developing
in addition to trying to bring all of
these native capabilities and
performance we're also trying to do
something really simple we're trying to
open up the web to all developers not
just developers who have been graced
with the ability to learn javascript
many people start out learning a C or
C++ class and they go and they build
applications that are useful and
interesting and everyone wants to have
access to those things but they've been
unable to bring those to the web so far
and we want to give them that
opportunity there are many different
coding languages that need to be brought
and we're looking forward to doing that
an example of that is the bullet physics
demo that we released with portable
Native Client let me navigate over here
well maybe navigate over here well you
can see a sliver of it that's something
let's expand this again cool this is
mostly a JavaScript application what
it's done is taken a see library the
bullet
physics library and just embed that
capability in itself now I can interact
with my Jenga thing I'm really bad at
Jenga I've learned that through this
application and I can as a JavaScript
developer take advantage of this C
library right here on my page and play
around with some things knock over lots
of bricks so that's one example of how
we could take advantage of portable
Native Client to bring native
performance to the web and native
capabilities now let's say that I'm
actually a C and C++ developer and
that's what I'm comfortable with all
right fine can also this is an example
of lua lua interpreter this is written
almost entirely in c and i can go and
take this up take my native code and run
it right here on the web here i have a
actually i don't know if this is going
to render very well in our weird leash
well donuts that's who doesn't like dogs
here so this is mostly a seal I see
application and I've brought it to the
web I brought it to all of the viewers
and people that can experience it there
so either way no matter what language I
develop in I now have access to the web
to bring that to all of the people who
want to interact with it
okay so you've seen some of the things
we're trying to bring to the web and
you've seen a demonstration in fact with
some of these things actually running in
the web so what is portable Native
Client portable Native Client is native
code security platform independence this
is the web we're talking about here we
wanted to run on these all these
platforms we talked about before and
performance performance as close to
Native as we can give you with security
so let's talk a little bit how about how
we give you access to native now this
touches a little bit about on Joe's
presentation earlier but we're using the
pepper API in order to give you access
to the native capabilities it's gives
you secure access to things like USB
opengl mouse cursor lock full screen and
tcp and UDP messaging this gives you
really all of the feature set of a
native application but in a secure
fashion ok so security I talked about
just a moment ago so you want to put
this wonderful piece that you've put
into your application now this is a
screenshot of Airmech which is not
running a pinnacle for full disclosure
but this is the sort of thing that the
people are doing with a portable Native
Client so you want to put your piece of
native code in the web well you know
they're all these browser AP is that the
plugin api's gave you access to there
are also underlying operating system
api's and we said before that you know
unfiltered access to those things was
what gave rise to the security issues
we've all come to know and loathe what
kind of security issues you know going
and snagging your cookies doing
something inappropriate with that going
and sending your credit card number
across site to some malicious site
putting a keylogger in that'll follow
you for the rest of your session turning
on your cam and watching tell sorts of
things that you don't want the the web
to know about or scraping your screen
and finding you know your bank account
numbers or other things that might be up
on another window these are the kinds of
things that unfiltered API access can
give you there that are really scary so
we're about providing access to the
features that Molly just talked about
but not through unfiltered access to
these api's so with regard to platform
independence Native Client from the
start was x86 we added
arm year or so ago and in fact as joe
said before you know for the top five
amazon laptops or our arm devices
running Chrome OS this is something we
have have a very central commitment to
and we also run on the other platforms
that the other desktop platforms that
chrome runs on windows mac linux chrome
alloys now it's really important to be
platform independent but I think you'll
all agree that we want to run on every
browser unfortunately right now pinnacle
is only is chrome only but if we want to
have a cross-browser story as well now
if you're developing for native this is
kind of what your your application
structure would look like you have your
C++ file it targets the pepper API to
get access to all of those native
capabilities which then talks to the
browser and gives you the right link up
if you're making a pinnacle application
you compile your C++ file to a portable
executable what we call apexi and that
talks to the pepper API which is
included in chrome now if you want to go
and run your application on another
browser you'd compile your C++ file
using and scripting into a JavaScript
file now that would start trying to talk
to the pepper API but that's not
implemented on another browser we've
created a solution called pepper jas
this links up the calls in your
JavaScript application to the JavaScript
API is in other browsers now your
application can go and run on multiple
browsers example is one of our demos
voronoi I go over here here i have about
i have the Voronoi application it has
all of these thoughts they're running
around cool can refresh it running in
the pinnacle version so that means that
I can hopefully scroll down here to the
bottom well hypothetically I could
scroll down to the bottom and show you
that I could bump up our thread count
and make this run even faster maybe I
can still do that cool
hypothetically fair enough um always
happens another option is that i could
be running that same demo right here on
my Nexus tablet which I could
potentially show you using the screen or
I could just hold it up and you could
all tell notice it's running it looks
wonderful and there's lots of points in
there animating and I would try and do
this but I don't think it would do
anything fair enough ok Somali gave you
the the visual demos so here's here's
the the boring text version of this
across a broad variety of benchmarks
that we've run we've seen over heads or
actually relative to native performance
in the eighty to ninety percent range so
we're able to give you a performance
which is very close to native while
keeping the security benefits we talked
about before so and we're not the only
ones people have in the the broad
benchmark Native Client as a you know
being the the closest sort of approach
to native code performance even after
the as MJ s announcement so so that's
what you get what do you have to do to
get a Native Client application going
and what's actually going on under the
hood so you have your cool piece of
source code use our tool called pinnacle
clang that's part of the so we based
this off the lvm toolchain the PEC c or
the portable executable is actually a
modified version of lvm bit code that
has been made a little better for
long-term use in the web you know once
you put something up on the web the
expectation is it's going to work for a
long time to come so we made some
simplifications that make that more
possible so you compile using our tool
chain and you add this again we have a
manifest file the manifest file gives
you a way to specify where to find the
the portable executable and also a way
to to specify some metadata some things
about relative translation time versus
delivered performance trade-offs and
such things you put in a bed tag in and
boom you have a page that's enabled to
to run for will Native Client now your
user comes and starts up the page that
you just put up
and the browser chrome is going to see
well there's that embed tag and it says
that I'm going to be referring to a
portable executable and of course it's
portable it's not something I can run
natively on the platform so it's going
to say I need a translation of that to
run on my platform so it'll ask for a
translation the translation then it's
done by something called the pinnacle
translator again that's based on part of
the lvm tool chain in this case it's one
of the lvm back ends and the translator
while streaming the portable executable
down is translating the portable
executable into something in this case a
native elf executable that actually runs
on your platform and running on your
platform okay we just I just told you
all the the things with security that
you want to prevent so we use something
called software fault isolation and
software fault isolation creates a
region that we call a sandbox that you
can guarantee that the executable can
only execute instructions that we've
looked at the browser's looked at that
the instructions are ones that are
acceptable and that they don't only
refer to memory that's in the
applications address range so with that
this little piece of the the Native
Client technology called a validator
actually validates those sets of
constraints and with that it can
determine whether it's possible for this
application to have access to these ap
is that we said we're dangerous before
and if it can't validate the executable
if you can't prove that it doesn't do
these bad things and we just flat refuse
to start the executable so on the other
hand if it can show that the set of
changes to the underlying instructions
are followed then we don't allow we
won't be able to get native access to
the unfiltered access to those api's and
it can run safely so if it starts
running we started running at that point
and we started running all the while
it's running if it wants to interact
with the outside system it interacts
through something we call in the Native
Client runtime the Native Client runtime
will also enforce security policies that
we talked about in just a second now you
might remember some of you that in fact
whenever you run a web page in Chrome
that page is actually running in an
outer sandbox and so one more thing the
Native Client sandbox is also running
inside the chrome sandbox so we have
sandboxes inside of San boxes before for
the inception challenged that's that's
anyway so we have sandboxes inside of
sand boxes and with this we've crafted
the cones of silence right so now we
have two processes that can't talk to
each other and of course that harkens
back to ppapi is the way that
applications can securely talk to the
browser and get access to these native
features that the application wants and
retain the security that we need for the
native code so we've told you a little
bit about why we need native code in the
web we've shown the performance benefits
you can get and we've told you a little
bit about how we do it how this works
under the hood so where are we going
with this next we're trying to bring
these native capabilities to the web
because it enables a really rich
interaction a really rich set of
applications that we believe should
exist but we're not quite done we want
to keep improving on our techniques on
how we get these applications up and
running I'm going to give you a little
bit of an analogy in explaining our
future directions on how to make this
even better first off we want to speed
up your lion we want to increase your
translation time a user navigates to
your page that's running a pending
pinnacle executable hu load as quick as
we can make it we also want to make you
even more capable give your lines and
claws we're going to give your c plus
plus plus exception handling and
vectorized instructions in pinnacle
we're also going to decrease the size of
your pinnacle bit code so that your page
can load and it'll download over those
crappy connections we've been talking
about all day as quickly as we can
finally we really want to be responsive
to you our developer community and
moving forward and figuring out what are
the things that you need in order to
make this the next rich platform and
next way to make really amazing
applications thank you so much for your
time please visit go natural calm if you
have any questions I'm not going to hold
you any longer go five minutes early
have some drinks and please come and
chat with us we'll be right up here
thank you so much for today it's been
wonderful and Cheers